- All right, everybody.
(audience cheering)
We are back with our
Barbie Dream Hour alongside
Margot Robbie, Issa Rae, Kate
McKinnon, America Ferrera.
(audience applauding)
She's excited. I like it.
(Kate wooing)
Yes.
(audience laughing)
Their new movie is called "Barbie"
and it's in theaters July 21st.
Barbie is one of the most
popular dolls in history,
if not the, but there
are so many other dolls
that we've known over the years as well.
It's time to find out who
remembers those dolls best
with a game called (laughs) Doll of Fame.
(cheerful music)
(audience applauding)
You're welcome, you're
welcome. We're clever.
I'm over here all alone
without a teammate.
So Jocko, come on.
You're looking very Ken.
Will you be the Ken to my Barbie?
(audience cheering)
(funky music)
- Come on!
- Come on over, teammate.
- [Jocko] Y'all are going down.
- Don't fail me. I'm just kidding.
(audience laughing)
Lord, could you host this game for us?
(angelic music)
(audience applauding)
- [Josh] Well, absolutely,
Kelly. You know me.
I'm just a Barbie girl in a
Barbie world of my own creation.
You know, heaven up here is
just one giant dreamboat playset
with a pool slide, you're gonna love it.
It's fantastic.
(Kelly laughing)
Anyway, let's get play a game here.
Now, in this game, every
answer is a doll or dolly.
Now, if you know the answer
you're going to hit the
button and shout it out.
(bell ringing)
Okay.
Now, if you're wrong,
you're gonna hear that
(buzzer sounding)
and you don't get any second guesses
and the other team can steal.
- [Kelly] Mkay, mkay.
- [Josh] Kelly and Jocko, you
are playing to win a prize
for the middle of the audience.
(audience applauding)
- Ready? Ready?
- We got you.
Right in the middle.
- [Josh] Make some noise. There you go.
Margot and Issa, you are
playing for the left side.
Make some noise, left side.
(audience cheering)
And America and Kate are
playing for the right.
(audience cheering)
- I love you, guys.
I love you guys.
- [Jocko] That's a lot of hype over there.
- [Josh] That's beautiful.
Bringing the nation together.
Okay, here is your first question.
- In this musical, Frank Sinatra
had the horse right here.
(phone ringing)
(audience laughing)
- Do I give it to you?
- Yes.
- "Guys and Dolls."
(Issa clapping)
- [Josh] It is "Guys and Dolls."
(audience cheering)
We got ourselves a game here.
Okay, come on now. Here we
go, here's your next question.
This foul mouthed red
hair doll might cut you
with the knife while you-
(phone ringing)
Go ahead.
Chucky.
(bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
- [Josh] It is Chucky. "Child's Play."
- Not a clue. Not a clue.
Not a clue. I didn't have a clue.
- You don't watch enough horror movies.
- I don't watch horror.
No, thanks. (laughs)
- [Josh] Watch out. Here's your
next question to mix it up.
These dolls have hair that
stands straight up, and Kelly-
(phone ringing)
- Damn it!
- Troll, right?
- Troll. Troll doll.
(bell ringing)
- [Josh] It is trolls.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Is this working?
- [Josh] All right, this doll
wrote some of the best songs
in American-
(phone ringing)
(bleep)
- You got it, you got it.
- Dolly Parton.
(bell ringing)
- [Josh] Oh, you got
it, it's Dolly Parton.
(audience cheering)
- You, like, cut each other
getting to the button.
- Yeah, we got so many rings on.
- Yeah, America's
competitive, sure. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- [Josh] Next question.
She was the wife of the fourth president
of the United States.
(phone ringing)
- I love you. No, you do it.
- Dolley Madison.
- [Josh] It is Dolley Madison.
(bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
- [Jocko] I would have
definitely not got that.
(motor revving)
- I would never have gotten that.
- Never.
- And I know, I just wouldn't have.
- [Josh] Also a tasty little
mini donut, the Dolley Madison.
Okay, now that sound of Barbie's Corvette
getting ready to leave means we have time
for just one more question.
As this is the final question
I'm gonna make it worth five points.
- We could take it.
- [Issa] Five points? All right.
- [Josh] This is it.
This is for the game.
(audience laughing)
The last question.
These dolls celebrated
different eras of US history.
(phone ringing)
(audience cheering)
- American Dolls!
- [Josh] You better know
it. It is American Dolls.
- Time's up and the big
group, our winners today,
are America and Kate.
(triumphant music)
I'm so glad you got that one right.
- We literally couldn't
have planned that better.
(audience laughing)
I would've been sad for you if you hadn't.
That was incredible.
- So this is a snippet
of what America was like.
(audience laughing)
- Of course everyone in
our audience is a winner
because it's my show
and that's what happens.
If you don't know Funboy,
they're a family company
that makes amazing pool floats for summer
like the ones you can
see in Barbie's Corvette.
Funboy just launched their
official "Barbie: the Movie"
pool float collection,
including the iconic
B inflatable pool float
and surfboard float.
They want you to experience
"Barbie: the Movie" in real life
so you're all getting a
$200 gift card to Funboy.
(audience cheering)
And because they know their dolls best,
photos of America and Kate will go up
on the chicks wall of champs
who beat Kelly Clarkson,
which I am happy for.
Thank you voice of God, and
thanks to the cast of "Barbie,"
everybody, you can see the
movie in theaters July 21st.